welcome back to CBS mornings and welcome
back to a big new development in our
exclusive joint investigation with
Kaiser health news into an unproven
Dental device some patients said it left
them with mangled mouths and even
missing teeth and we've learned the FDA
which regulates medical and dental
devices is now looking into this device
and we found there is another similar
device on the market also our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
has been here with more Anna good
morning yeah good morning Tony a former
agency official tells us after seeing
our reports about The Dental device
called an anterior growth guidance
Appliance or AGA some FDA officials told
her they're very concerned
patient after patient told us they were
left with pain and loose teeth from an
unproven Dental device a device they
were shocked to learn later had no
government approval I thought that if an
appliance was sold at a dentist office
then that it it had to go through some
sort of FDA approval Having learned that
it was just not is pretty shocking this
Appliance needs to be pulled off the
market it should be it shouldn't even be
out there the device What's called the
interior growth guidance Appliance or
AGA a retainer-like appliance promoted
as something that could expand the upper
jaw without surgery it's predictable
it's stable and it's safe the agas
inventor Tennessee dentist Dr Steve
gallella seen here in Australia training
dentists to use his device in 2017 has
claimed the AGA could cure problems like
TMJ and sleep apnea can you cure TMJ yes
can you cure mild to moderate sleep
apnea yes he said the device has been
used on more than ten thousand people
but a joint CBS News Ahn investigation
found at least 20 people who have sued
Dr gallella and others over their AGA
treatment all of them said he consulted
on their treatment plans with their
dentists one of those people former
professional clarinetist Boya krugulia
told us after her Agate treatment her
front teeth flared out and were loose
and painful and doctors she consulted
later had to remove her Forefront teeth
they're really gone you know and um
and to see yourself without teeth is a
bizarre experience
Dental Specialists we interviewed who
have seen former AGA patients told us
the device pushes teeth out of the bone
I've not seen one patient that has it it
had anything good come from this device
nothing this is snake oil this is
this is crazy yet we found no evidence
the FDA which regulates Dental devices
was even aware of the AGA it wasn't
registered in fda's medical device
database now I'm hearing that FDA is
very interested very concerned about
this device former FDA senior policy
advisor Cara Tenenbaum says almost
immediately after our reports aired FDA
officials reached out to her my
understanding is that FDA is looking
into this device to see what kind of
regulatory and legal Authority it may
have over the device and what actually
the device does to people manufacturers
are supposed to register devices with
the FDA but in court the AG is
manufacturer said it has no record of
communicating with the agency about the
device before making or selling it it
claimed the AGA falls into the least
risky class of devices similar to a
dental retainer and is exempt from a
pre-market review under an exemption for
dental Labs inventor Dr gallella said in
a court deposition he believed the AGA
was outside the fda's jurisdiction Dr
gallella he declined to answer our
questions last month I wanted to talk
with you about your AG device treatment
okay talk to you the FDA would not
confirm whether it's evaluating the
Agate device but CBS News and khn have
now also learned that the Las Vegas
Institute a training company that
previously taught dentists to use the
AGA now trains dentists to use another
device the anterior remodeling Appliance
or ARA which its CEO has described an
lvi Facebook group posts as almost
exactly the same Appliance and Dental
Specialists we spoke to said they are
similarly concerned about that device
too former patient gregulia hopes the
FDA will look into not just the AGA but
other devices as well I think people
deserve to know what it is they're
buying into and what it is exactly that
it's going to do for them or not do for
them so that they can weigh the benefits
and risks
Dr gallella threw his attorney again
declined to answer questions for this
story his attorney previously told us
the device now called the Osseo
restoration Appliance when properly used
is safe and can achieve beneficial
results for the patient he said Dr
galella had had no complaints prior to
the lawsuits the name change feels
notable but there are Dennis elsewhere
in the country other dentists were
advertising the original uh device any
change to their circumstances are they
still doing that right so they've sort
of picked up on galella's Dr galella's
teachings and they were advertising that
for example it could grow or remodel the
adult jaw without surgery these are
dentists around the country however
since our investigation aired we have
found that at least 11 of those Dental
websites have removed any mention of the
egg this is what we mean when we say
Anna Warner gets results that's right
Anna thank you so much you do not want
Anna Warren or knocking out no you don't
no you don't well we do
it thanks a bunch